we begin this half-hour with another
rescue this one in Florida a routine
weekly fishing trip quickly turned into
a life-saving mission for a kayaker just
as Dawn was breaking Thursday he spotted
an unusual sight in the waters south of
Tampa a partially submerged car with a
woman inside a lady had been in the
water with her ography we don't know how
long she seems to be okay we're gonna
try to get it right now Rob Goodman's
kayaking trip quickly turned into a
rescue mission early Thursday morning in
Venice Florida I was probably about
right here when I noticed the car
because it was just becoming daylight
inside an 81 year old woman trapped for
almost ten hours in the water before her
car was spotted
we got about right about here when her
hand came out the window Goodman and
nearby paddleboard or edy caster worked
together to free the driver racing to
get her out before high tide came in she
was leaning with a head up to breathe we
opened the door I was able to talk to
her she was still aware enough to be
able to kind of mobilize police say the
vehicle entered the water when the
driver made a wrong turn and ended up on
a boat ramp on the side of the bay the
car actually starting to move when our
units got there was starting to float
away lucky that she was found when she
was found because otherwise it could
have been much worse that is an
understatement police say the
unidentified driver is in stable
condition and is expected to be a-ok I
mean just being trapped for that long
and not being able to wow